nous at on assez proclamait répéter
asséné ces temps derniers
ce soir là on peut dire un plan
marketing parfait presque mieux que star
wars que c'était le scandale du festival
de cannes le film que même les critiques
du masque et la plume les plus endurcis
n'avait pu regarder sans frémir ça sent
l'été le mot insoutenable bref
irréversible de gaspar noé avec monica
bellucci vincent cassel et albert
dupontel a été montré à minuit minuit
trente dans mon souvenir aux festivals
et sorti le même jour dans toute la
france ce l'histoire commence donc dans
une boîte au mot joliment nommé le
rectum ou vincent cassel cherche tenez
vous bien le ténia le ténia et méchant
hein je peux le dire c'est pas une
insulte il est méchant
il a un copain dont le crâne sera
méchamment enfoncée à coups d'extincteur
bref y'a de la vengeance dans l'air car
monica bellucci faut revenir en arrière
en sainte a été violée au cours d'une
scène que maintenant tout le monde
connaît même ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu
très longue scène bon je m'arrête là
même les inrocks ont dû revenir à la
formule télérama sq du pour et du contre
ses membres bono qui étaient contre je
crois que j'ai pas vu depuis la création
des inrocks 1 pour et un contre est
juste un truc que j'avais oublié
résultat c'est le plus important 32
salles à paris c'est les chiffres qu'on
a trente-deux mille spectateurs c'est à
dire quasiment un bide quand on voit le
lancement de ce film on va pas reprendre
l'histoire en détail mais rappelez quand
même pas ce que vous en pensez les uns
les autres on a été un peu rapide
dimanche dernier à cannes
donc soyons peut-être plus précis
aujourd'hui à paris daniel franchement
monsieur gaspar noé qui avait fait un
moyen métrage est un long métrage bien
intéressante
les carnets seul contre tous il y avait
un personnage qui était le boucher c'est
les films extrêmement antipathique
extrêmement désagréable mais avec un
vrai personnage et qui disait quelque
chose sur la misère du monde et lamy
r d des gens dans ce monde là il a
beaucoup à montrer et rien à dire il n'y
a rien à dire c'est absolument et encore
quand tu dis a montré il faut voir il
veut montrer
il veut montrer un viol en temps réel
c'est très mal très très mal de violer
les femmes très très mal voilà alors ce
qui est curieux c'est pour le courrier
ça oui c'est très très mal ne dites pas
que je n'en sais très mal de violer les
femmes et ça sert pas à grand-chose de
défense et la tête des violeurs avec un
extincteur parce que ça ne guérit toi
cette grande douleur
oui mais enfin bon ça enfin on ne sait
pas qui fait très noir il fait très noir
dans cette boîte il ya des corps en rut
et safe est très très noir au rectum il
fait très noir et le ténia est très bon
non ce qui est désagréable vraiment
désagréable en dehors du fait que c'est
très désagréable de voir un viol pendant
dix minutes c'est que tout est basé sur
on vous montre des choses à l'envers
donc on va vers l'enfer de l'enfer vers
le paradis du noir vers la lumière du de
l'atrocité vers le bonheur perdu mais
tout ça c'est parce que il ya un couple
de chouettes copains qui s'appelle
monica bellucci et vincent cassel qui
voulait faire mumuse avec moi gaspar noé
donc c'est un couple formidable de
chouettes copains
tant et si bien que comme y'a pas de
personnages comme n'y a rien comme ya
rien à dire on est tout à coup
effectivement en face de ce couple qui
est d'une beauté absolument
extraordinaire on assiste alors réveille
alors qu'alain matinale et tout a
continué bon sens mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait là a violé à notre tour l'intimité
de ce couple magnifique tout nu qui est
là qui se fait des buts et on est très
embêté andy bell est vraiment excusé
nout si on est en train d'en payer 50
balles pour pouvoir mais vraiment
vraiment on ressort dans l'au delà c'est
bien mais bien vu que tu as comme vous
êtes très heureux ça va bientôt finir et
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
bêtes
finalement deux bêtes voilà je crois que
c'est ça quand même très très loin du
scandale annoncé michèle ouimet ce qui
intéressait en fait gaspar noé c'était
de filmer ce couple dans ses ébats
étaient terrain dans une sorte de
voyeurisme un film un peu porno sur un
couple faire ce que kubrick n'avait pas
fait dans eyes wide shut
kidman et tom cruise et je sipa kubrick
pour rien puisque c'est la grande
passion de gaspar noé il ya des
références à 2001 mon fils mais je pense
aussi d'ailleurs lui 0,20 cent à
nouakchott et ce qui frappe en ensuite
c'est justement au contraire l'absence
d'intelligence c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est un film qui est qui est
complètement mal pensée qui est qui et à
ces irresponsables qui appartiennent ces
pays n'est pas tout seul il a il avait
dû qu'il avait beaucoup de talent dans
d'un seul contre tout ce qui était un
film ambigu gênant mettrais même du
point de vue de la mise en scène
l'utilisation des titres et c'est un
film très original
ici il se laisse aller un peu comme une
sorte d'adolescents attardés qui
ricanent dans son coin qui dit je vais
faire des choses qui vont provoquer tout
le monde avec une sorte de il atteint 35
ans veut dire c'est pas inapte à 16 ans
c'est ça qui est assez grave et et c'est
plus beau dos et en même temps ça
appartient à tout un courant du cinéma
français je pense à assassins de caisse
vie je pense à nikita de besson je pense
à dobermann verbal bien c'est à dire
dans une époque où on est justement à
une époque de la pulsion à la télévision
tous les soirs la violence est une sorte
de deux de valorisation de l'affect sait
on on devrait au contraire amener les
gens n'ont pas ne pas avoir des offres
sensuelle et émotionnel mais aussi un
minimum de réflexion là je pense que
c'est un film très irresponsable dans
une sorte de violence d'une gratuité
totale aux revirements les défenseurs
disent oui mais l'honnêteté c'est de
montrer le viol en temps réel sinon
c'est faux à ce moment-là friesland john
ford tous les grands artistes de
l'histoire du cinéma sont tous plantés
parce qu'ils nous ont pas montré à
chaque fois que j'ai vu un type qui
était qui recevait une balle des
entrailles qui sortent d'un crâne
écrabouillé etc donc il faut revoir
toute l'histoire de l'art alain moi je
pense que le je vais en parler à travers
vraiment le festival de cannes puisque
c'était fait pour scandalisé le festival
alors au début du festival nous avons vu
et tout le festival a adoré un film de
michael moore qui s'appelle un
documentaire sur le comedd armes va pas
le commerce les arts des armes et
l'utilisation des armes aux états unis
film extrêmement bien fait d'où il
ressort que ce qui est terrifiant à
notre époque c'est moins le
l'universalité des armes qu'on trouve
partout que la banalisation des images
de violence or ce même festival
là je parle des gens en tongs ou un an
dimanche et que j'ai accompagné avec qui
j'étais
ces mêmes gens très bons vins des tabous
enjeux précis mais aussi en bleu le
premier a pas grand mais non c'est rare
ont fait un triomphe à michael moore
dans les mêmes conditions douze jours
après c'était une image fascinante s'il
y avait des futurs fellini de
l'assistance vraiment je leur demande de
réfléchir à ça on a vu une ovation
debout et c'était une société entière
qui applaudissait ce qui était en train
de la détruire
parce que monsieur gaspar noé nous dit
le temps détruit tout c'est la thèse de
son film et ethias qui rien n'est plus
faux le temps guérit les blessures le
temps bonif il vint le temps bonifie
parfois les hommes mais la même violence
la violence est une certitude détruites
ou la banalisation de la violence est en
train de faire exploser la société leur
accueil nous vivons et aimé ce film
c'est être sur le titanic et être
content je précise d'ailleurs pour nos
auditeurs qu'au festival de cannes
j'ai lu une déclaration dans le journal
local du capitaine des pompiers qui a
dit en voyant le film c'est insoutenable
frédéric bonnaud oui mais insoutenable
salle et enfin moi j'avais envie d'être
ailleurs pendant la projection j'avais
envie que ça s'arrête simplement ce qui
me gêne un peu dans ce que vient de dire
alain sait que c'est que c'est que 28 en
claque tu prends vraiment une attitude
morale par rapport au film c'est à dire
rendre les attitudes morales on a
également un tabassage dans le
magnifique film des calories ce maquis
qu'on verra à la rentrée
il est tout à fait c'est un tabassage
nécessaire si je peux dire il fallait le
montrer ils le montrent il en fait pas
des tonnes il en rajoute payet pas de
complaisance mais là il est évident
qu'ils se vautre dans le viol des dents
face et c'est terrifiant c'est dégoûtant
c'est ouais je sais pas moi je continue
à penser que l'attitude moral par
rapport aux oeuvres d'art n'est pas la
bonne attitude donc c'est pas tellement
ça qui m'embête dans le film ce qui
m'embête dans le film c'est sa pauvreté
et sa bêtise pauvreté parce que c'est ce
qu'on appelle pour être aussi vulgaire
que gaspar noé un one shot
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment on a une
idée un couple d'acteurs qui sont prêts
à mouiller la chemise comme on dit et on
va faire un film or l'idée c'est la
femme
l'idée de raconter le film à rebours est
à l'envers l'envers le fameux d'où le
fameux irréversible donc moi ce qui me
surprend un film comme un film coréen
magnifique
non mais sans battre et nouveau michel
sordi à 3 mara dans l'indifférence
générale cette affirmation merveilleux
qui prenait toute l'histoire une
addition c'est vraiment une idée une
pauvre idée du ce de films une pauvre
idée de scandales et une pauvre idée de
la richesse du cinéma voilà c'est ça qui
est frappant dans le film c'est à quel
point tout ça est mince pauvre pas
intéressant maintenant il ya autre chose
qui me qui moi me dérange plus en plus
que évidemment j'ai pas tellement envie
de voir ça sur un écran c'est en fait le
puritanisme profond du film c'est pas du
tout et c'est là où je ne suis pas très
d'accord avec alain c'est pas du tout un
film audacieux sulfureux c'est un film
au contraire très puritain qui dit
regardez qu'est ce que c'est la mauvaise
pulsions regardez qu'est ce que c'est
les mauvaises pulsions et regardez où ça
nous mène serre que le film va de
l'enfer absolue vraiment l'enfer ce
rectum cette boîte de nuit je passe sur
le côté homophobes du salaire du film
qui me paraît assez évident et donc de
l'enfer on remonte au paradis et là
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans le paradis un
petit couple qui fait l'amour le samedi
après midi parce qu'ils travaillent pas
et puis le soir ils sortent avec leurs
potes qui est l'ex de la fille à une
soirée qui va mal se terminer
et donc voilà ils dorment on imagine
qu'ils viennent de faire l'amour il
jouissait bon très bien et le type dit à
la fille dont vincent cassel dia monica
bellucci genre je sais plus qui lui dit
exactement mais c'est du genre tu as un
beau cul je t'encule très bien c'est les
paroles c'est les mots du film une
demi-heure sont pas les siens c'est ça
que je veux dire je ne fais que répéter
une demi-heure avant dont suivez bien
puisque même une heure avant suivez bien
puisque le film se déroule à l'envers
cette même monica bellucci a été
massacrée et violée par sodomie
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'est
ce que dit la chine que si on a envie de
[ __ ] sa femme évidemment
visiblement puisque ils sont amoureux
avec son accord l'après midi here is lui
arriver une chose tout à fait abominable
près le soir également par sodomie
c'est à la fois des bills puritains
idiot pauvres c'est enfin je sais pas
c'est à oublier et ce que je pense et
dont on aura besoin d'un jour et justin
bien là dessus parce que c'est vrai qu'à
tarnos et quand même quelqu'un
d'intéressant sont moins
un métrage est son premier long métrage
était interdit donc qu'il arrête de
faire des one shots et qu'ils
réfléchissent un peu irréversible gaspar
noé pas de réaction sur ce film là non
vous n'avez pas vu vous avez raison
[Musique]